[Música]
nací en esta ciudad de guanajuato
según uno a la perfección pero conozco
bastante bien a la ciudad su comunidad y
a su gente
mi abuela nació en 1902 en el mozo
mineral del monte de san nicolás hoy un
pueblo mágico semi abandonado en su
momento un bullicioso mineral ella vivió
ahí toda su niñez y parte de su
adolescencia y siempre nos cautiva va
con historias como la primera vez que
subió un auto en mineral la casa grande
y su huerto los pilones de oro
muchas historias más en aquel entonces
el país estaba aún muy agitado y si de
por si la vida era dura por ser un
mineral enclavado en lo alto de las
montañas
saqueadores y bandoleros por
revolucionarios le hacían aún más duro
recuerdo que mi abuela decía no lo tires
aún puede servir ella creció y fue
educado en una comunidad donde los
recursos eran limitados y cualquier
material altamente valorado desde lo más
básico como el alimento que se hacía mal
tiempo podría escasear y había que
traerlo desde otro lugar hasta la hoja
de lata el acero y refacciones de todo
tipo
no había desechables y todo lo que se
utilizaba trastes frascos o contenedores
eran rellenados una y otra vez con los
insumos necesarios
y más allá cualquier objeto al dejar de
funcionar era utilizado por sus partes y
sus materiales como parche para otros
seguro había desechos pero libera
utilizar las cosas hasta que de verdad
ya no podían funcionar más con esta idea
como premisa de vida fuimos educados
cuando yo era niño mi padre tuvo un
negocio de fotocopia de fotocopias
ahí se generaban como residuos mucho
papel cajas de cartón tubos de cartón
cubiertas plásticas y anillos para
encuadernación por otro lado mi familia
nunca fue entusiasta de los juguetes
bélicos eran más de darnos el set de
bomberos el set de hospital o las
carreras de autos que resultó de esta
combinación que terminamos dotado a esos
bomberos con naves espaciales tanques y
aviones con armas láser todo hecho de
papel y cartón
descubrimos un mundo infinito de
posibilidades con un poco de pegamento y
grapas
recuerdan estos personajes que
capturaban espectros pues nos hicimos
las mochilas con reactores de fusión y
disparadores
casa vamos los espectros nos hacíamos
armaduras medievales completas desde el
casco hasta las espinilleras escudos y
espadas y nos vaciamos en combates hasta
que se destrozaban las armaduras y
teníamos que correr a repararlas sin
duda fue una buena niñez con mucha
creatividad y además pudimos superar el
obstáculo de la necesidad creada o
adquirida porque se nos mostró que hay
muchas cosas que deseamos pero que no
necesitamos siempre no se nos enseñó a
valorar las cosas no tanto por su costo
sino por el trabajo que se requería para
que las cosas estuvieran ahí desde que
tengo uso de razón he amado la
naturaleza y creo que las ciencias son
una buena opción para comprender los
entrañables secretos del universo
inicié mis estudios
universitarios en química pero
finalmente mi formación es como
ingeniero ambiental lo que me recuerda
que hay mucha gente que cree y me dice
que es mi obligación mi deber y mi mi
responsabilidad cuidar el medio ambiente
y están equivocados
ese trabajo de ese deber y esa
obligación es de todos y cada uno de
nosotros yo me esfuerzo siempre para
difundir opciones para lograrlo en
tiempos más recientes tuve la
oportunidad de participar en la creación
de una pequeña empresa donde le plantea
al propietario la posibilidad de separar
los residuos que se generaban en el
proceso productivo y ahí inició de
manera más bien improvisada y casi por
instinto este viaje en el mundo de los
residuos separábamos lo básico cartón
plástico y metales muchas de las veces
observamos que los servicios de
recolección no respetaban nuestra
separación y volvían a mezclar los
residuos en su transporte es por eso que
en más de una ocasión recuerdo que al
salir de trabajar y por las calles
vacías de la ciudad me llevaba a casa un
atado de cartón o una bolsa con
plásticos para asegurarme de su destino
para reciclar
esto continuó por un par de años más
hasta que en colaboración con gabriel
solano renato guevara y paulette
elizarrarás se formó el proyecto de
recuperación de residuos en el que
recolectamos los residuos valorables de
algunos comercios iniciamos con solo
tres lugares pero en el plazo de dos a
tres meses ya eran más de 70 y seguíamos
aumentando e incluso algunos
particulares entusiastas se unieron a la
lista el objetivo del proyecto era
evitar que los residuos llegaran al
tiradero municipal el servicio a los
negocios consistía en la recolección
personalizada y especializada de los
residuos al interior de los comercios la
logística en la ruta de recolección se
basó en puntos de acopio y un transporte
más eficiente para los espacios
reducidos de las calles de esta ciudad
de guanajuato los residuos serán
llevados a un sitio donde los separa
vamos y les dábamos un tratamiento para
almacenarlos y después comercializarlos
en una segunda etapa del proyecto se
buscaría utilizar algunos de los
materiales separados para innovación en
materiales de construcción el proyecto
continuó por varios meses más e incluso
contratamos a un par de personas al
final manejábamos entre el 50 y el 90
por ciento de los residuos de los
negocios con los que trabajábamos según
el giro comercial porque no manejábamos
residuos orgánicos pero justo en el
momento en que la actividad dejaba de
ser un proyecto para iniciar una empresa
formal decidimos terminar el proyecto
de ello adquirimos mucha información muy
valiosa
primero confirmamos que una solución al
problema de los residuos es la correcta
gestión de los residuos a través de la
separación de origen y de una estrecha
colaboración entre el generador y el
servicio de disposición si nosotros un
grupo de jóvenes entusiastas con solo un
vehículo de tres cuartos de tonelada lo
logramos
que se podrá hacer con un poco más de
recursos es cuestión de voluntad
también este ejercicio demostró que se
podía disminuir un 50 por ciento de los
residuos que van al tiradero y en el
mejor de los casos hasta un 70 a 90 por
ciento ya que la mayoría de los residuos
son valorables si están limpios y
separados la otra gran parte de los
residuos son orgánicos y pueden ser
degradados o compostados en el lugar
es cuestión de voluntad otra cosa de la
que nos percatamos es que hay una gran
cantidad de personas que están
dispuestas a colaborar y en general si
hubiera una reglamentación y una
regulación todos deberíamos acatar un
mandato de ley es cuestión de voluntad
aprendimos que una correcta
administración de los recursos
destinados a la recolección y gestión de
los residuos es imperante recolectar los
residuos mezclados y sucios acumulados
en el tiradero es más costoso además de
los costos ambientales que implementar
programas de recolección separación
donde participe de manera efectiva toda
la población
sabemos que actualmente la recolección y
el manejo de los residuos es una
actividad muy degradada que no se paga y
no se valora de manera correcta incluso
hay quien dirá que es una actividad
sucia y eso es nuestra culpa es nuestra
responsabilidad no toda la basura tiene
que estar sucia es cuestión de como
nosotros la generamos y la desechamos y
de si tenemos o sentimos empatía por las
personas que trabajan con ella es
cuestión de como el sistema de
recolección la maneja también es
cuestión de corresponsabilidad entre
gobierno y sociedad es cuestión de
voluntad
creo que estamos equivocando el camino
como sociedad y es un tema bastante
complicado y delicado porque puede herir
susceptibilidades porque tenemos
necesidades básicas yo les llamo
necesidades mínimas vitales como salud
casa vestido y sustento todas están
incluidas en la declaración de los
derechos humanos sin embargo estas
necesidades crean otras necesidades
digamos de infraestructura como empleo
transporte de seguridad educación
etcétera y entonces surgen otras
necesidades un poco más complicadas o
subjetivas como el arte el esparcimiento
la individualidad la pertenencia
etcétera así surgen ideologías y los
sistemas sociales que se suponen a
través de la historia hemos cambiado y
aprendido de ellos
hoy un sistema social de beber por el
bien de la mayoría debe abogar por la
igualdad de derechos y oportunidades
para todos esto es lo que nos da esa
idea de libertad pero en algún punto del
recorrido entre cubrirlas
las necesidades básicas y las complejas
necesidades de los sistemas sociales
actuales perdimos el rumbo
como es posible que teniendo tantos
recursos naturales como los hay en el
mundo tanta innovación tecnológica tanto
conocimiento y sabiduría haya tanta
carencia precariedad y desigualdad como
es posible que haya tanto desperdicio de
energía de alimentos de recursos y
materias primas que no me malentiendan
este tipo de acontecimientos han sido
recurrentes a lo largo de la historia
pero en nuestra realidad han ido
demasiado lejos como es posible que haya
sociedades con hábitos de consumo tales
que parece como si hubiera cinco
planetas tierra para cubrir sus
necesidades y hay en cambio sociedades
que no pueden ni disfrutar de los
recursos que tienen en su entorno algo
estamos haciendo mal no tenemos
conciencia ni como sociedad
como humanidad y precisamente uno de los
problemas más grandes que tenemos como
sociedad y como humanidad desde que nos
volvimos sedentarios y establecimos los
primeros centros de población en la
antigua grecia en la antigua mesopotamia
son los residuos todos los objetos que
producimos como humanidad dejan de
servir en un momento determinado y se
convierten en residuos desde las cosas
más grandes como edificios y mega
estructuras hasta los objetos más
pequeños y cotidianos como un lápiz o un
vaso
a medida que avanza la técnica los
materiales cambian y surgen nuevos y
mejorados líquidos sólidos gases más
resistentes más persistentes y todos se
vuelven residuos que sin una gestión
responsable tienen un destino incierto y
la amada en las más de las veces
perjudicial para nosotros mismos es un
problema que los residuos no lleguen a
un sitio de disposición final porque
provocan puntos de contaminación del
suelo del agua fauna nociva incendios
contaminación visual o también son
arrastrados por las corrientes y
descubrimientos hasta los cuerpos de
agua o hacia el océano cuando nos mejor
de los casos los residuos son
gestionados y llevados a un sitio sucede
que en el mundo la mayoría de estos
lugares no cumplen con las las
características mínimas y crean
problemas como la generación de gases
infiltraciones escurrimientos de
lixiviados
todos los problemas antes mencionados
suceden en mayor proporción debido a la
cantidad de residuos depositados en un
solo lugar por otro lado
de productos bienes y servicios continúa
y requiere ser abastecida con materias
primas
otro problema de no gestionar y
aprovechar los residuos es que para
mantener la cadena productiva se
requiere estar extrayendo y procesando
continuamente tales materias primas y
recursos naturales en vez de aprovechar
los materiales que ya fueron extraídos
esto además de acabar con los recursos
naturales de los puntos de extracción
deja desolación rompe el balance natural
y libera sustancias que de otra manera
estarían confinadas como los
hidrocarburos o los metales pesados
lo ideal sería siempre pensar y hacer
los responsables de dónde vienen y
adónde van todas las cosas los bienes y
servicios que usamos y que nos rodean
esa idea como una forma de vida debe
influir en la forma de comprar consumir
reutilizar y de desechar siempre
pensando en el origen de los materiales
y en su destino final es difícil
sobrellevar estas prácticas o este modo
de vida en una sociedad que está
orientada al consumo que te enseña que
es más fácil comprar algo nuevo que
reparar o reutilizar las cosas que que
te vende todo con envoltura caja y una
envoltura otra vez una sociedad que te
ofrece cosas que no necesitas y te crean
necesidades sólo para asegurar que el
consumo continúe no se trata de dejar
las comodidades que el progreso y la
tecnología nos han dado pero sí de
usarlas con responsabilidad y mesura la
mayoría de las personas especialmente
las que vivimos en grandes conglomerados
urbanos
damos por hecho que los bienes y
servicios están a disposición inmediata
y pareciera que siempre han estado ahí
cuando al abrir una llave tenemos agua
potable o lo primero un interruptor
tenemos iluminación cuando tenemos
alimento fresco en nuestro refrigerador
o algunos pasos en un comercio cuando
consumimos carne pero nunca hemos tocado
una vaca o un pollo o un cerdo y mucho
menos hemos tenido que pensar en matarlo
para comerlo mira a tu alrededor y
piensa si alguna vez te preocupó de
dónde venían los materiales de las cosas
que te rodean la silla en la que te
sientas la pantalla que miras el suelo
que pisas las paredes a tu alrededor la
energía que consumes vivir así con esta
indiferencia y esa falta de respeto al
origen de las cosas es lo que devalúa
nuestra sociedad y al ambiente en este
punto usted podría pensar pero yo pago
por el agua pago para comer sin tener
que matar pago por el techo la ropa y
todo lo que uso pensar así es un grave
error ya que el precio monetario que
pagamos por lo que consumimos no refleja
en absoluto el costo real
porque las empresas les importa poco si
las materias primas se agotan en un
lugar simplemente cambiar cambiarán de
proveedor les importa poco si sus
procesos contaminan mientras nadie se
queje las empresas bajan sus costos
empleando la mano de obra más barata y
se establecen donde las leyes
ambientales no son fuertes o ni siquiera
existen agotando los recursos del lugar
y empobreciendo comunidades enteras
ninguna empresa incluye en el precio de
sus productos el costo de limpiar
transportar tratar procesar o disponer
los residuos en los que se convierten
estos sin mencionar los problemas
sociales y de salud que generan una vez
más no estoy diciendo que ser un
empresario vivir de una empresa del
tamaño que sea esté mal pero hace falta
tener conciencia del problema y voluntad
para dar solución se requiere
corresponsabilidad entre productor y
consumidor entre gobiernos y población
si bien es cierto que un problema de
esta magnitud solo puede ser solucionado
desde las cúpulas más altas de nuestro
sistema social a través de los gobiernos
o organismos sociales estableciendo
regulaciones de explotación consumo
comercio y disposición orientadas al
respeto y valoración real y ambiental de
las cosas también es cierto que nosotros
como individuos debemos dejar la apatía
ambiental que tenemos y asumir nuestra
responsabilidad
en el consumo de los productos y la
generación de los residuos
debemos informarnos para tomar
decisiones conscientes en nuestro día a
día desde la elección de un producto
sobre otro basándonos en la
responsabilidad de la empresa o en su
facilidad para reciclar hasta la
decisión de cambiar hábitos para reducir
los efectos adversos que provocamos al
ambiente ser conscientes de la medida en
que agotamos los recursos naturales de
nuestro entorno y preocuparnos por
conservarlos para las próximas
generaciones
es a lo que llamamos sustentabilidad
y recuerda que al menos todos los
residuos que tú generas son tu
responsabilidad
dejemos ya la apatía y tomemos cartas en
el asunto
infórmate y actúa siempre hay la opción
de separar reciclar o compostar busca
donde en tu comunidad o inicia tu las
acciones un largo viaje inicia por un
paso los grandes cambios inician con uno
pequeño cambia tu mundo hoy tú decides
es cuestión de voluntad gracias